so now let's get into the arguably most
cartoonish moment of kovat 19 nonsense
from the weekend involving our great
fearless mango colored leader Donald
Trump Friday afternoon Trump bragged
that thanks to his great work no one in
the united states had died from the
virus hours later someone died from the
virus a man named Jeff Duchin a Public
Health Officer for Seattle and in his
completely loony press-conference Donald
Trump referred to this man as a
wonderful woman who sadly has passed
away take a look at this at this moment
we have 22 patients in the United States
currently that have corona virus
unfortunately one person passed away
overnight which was a wonderful woman a
medically high-risk patient in her late
50s four others are very ill so it was
not a wonderful woman who passed away it
was dr. Jeff Duchin I've actually never
really heard Trump referred to women as
wonderful and here he happens to be
talking about a man without even knowing
it which seems ironic in some kind of
weird harebrained way the numbers that
Trump mentioned 22 cases those numbers
are well outdated as of hours ago the US
is over 80 cases and more importantly
the u.s. also now at two deaths two
deaths and the numbers are unfortunately
not improving with every passing day it
shouldn't really surprise us though that
a guy who can't understand how wind
works would be this confused about kovat
19 remember when Trump said the
following an economy based on wind I
never understood wind you know I know
windmills very much I've studied it
better than anybody I know it's very
expensive they're made in China and
Germany mostly very few made here almost
none but they're manufactured tremendous
if you're into this tremendous fumes
gases are spewing into the atmosphere
you know we have a world right so the
world is tiny compared to the universe
so tremendous tremendous amount of fumes
in everything you talk about the carbon
footprint fumes are spilling into the
air it's for spilling whether it's in
China Germany's going into the air sorry
their air everything right
a brutal relentless attack on wind and
windmills only one step removed from
literally yelling at clouds by the
President of the United States so this
is a micro Trump story Trump identifies
the first victim as a wonderful woman
when it was actually a man but as usual
with Trump the micro is emblematic it's
a microcosm of the macro and in this
case the macro is that we have a guy who
just has no idea what's going at all
period with regard to the virus and I
actually have been weirdly conditioned
by the Trump administration from their
constant lies in such a way that I was
sort of calm about the virus until Trump
said there's nothing to worry about
now I'm stocking up on anything that is
even mentioned as possibly being useful
to have ranging from zinc lozenges to
hand sanitizer and who knows what else
it reminded me of when Trump says he has
total confidence in some staffer and
then 48 hours later the staffers been
fired when Trump says everything's fine
we have nothing to worry about and
Democrats are over blowing this that's
when I start to get worried and I'm sort
of exaggerating but in a sense it is
true that when Trump says Everett says
everything's fine and it's people trying
to hurt me politically that are telling
you otherwise that actually is a red
flag that we need to go and look into
exactly what it is that's going on one
of our sponsors today is a game called
lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep
those promises when you're in office all
of the laws you pass affect your
country's happiness and safety health
care environment you can abolish laws
that are already in place you can ratify
the Constitution you decide if you want
the government to be a healthy democracy
or authoritarian tyranny you can be
corrupt and take bribes political
assassinations are part of the game it's
nuts actually it's a really good time it
doesn't get old because you'll never
play it the same way twice this is not
some cheesy free-to-play game it's very
clear that a lot of time went into the
development it has very positive reviews
on Steam and in the App Store's four and
a half stars or higher on all platforms
go to david pakman.com slash game which
is where you can watch the trailer
download the game for Steam iOS and
Android
that's david pakman.com slash game